he is the only living ex-
chancellor who was still able to speak unfortunately there
is also ms merkel as chancellor but apart from
that there is only him only
gerhard schröder saw a lot he
in view of things from vw to
digital to staging of
course all  we have that now here
with us, above all in the video,
by the way, after the conversation with gerhard schröder, i was
still available with him,
we invited anna Schlachtplatte to eat
and so first of all it was
excellent the podcast now
maybe it will hopefully be  also
on anna schröder good day I'm happy
that we're here are probably also
podcast yes indeed and not
without success we are of course happy and
how did it come about oh that used to be
government spokesman willing to the
organized has convinced me
that  are nowadays interviews
important in newspapers i am
still a newspaper reader magazine reader but
that you have direct communication  ation should not be
ignored and in this respect
I am happy about the success of this
podcast, recently Friedrich
Merz said that I had
shifted the relevance a bit in the area of
ws towards which the news
eally causes and away from
hich the news  spre
the word like it used to be if you agree
i wouldn't quite agree with him i
think that both belong together of
course you're happy if you
can address the audience directly on
the other hand
quality journalism in
newspapers magazines is enormously important for
democracy
because  in quality journalism, if it
is done and if there is no
attempt to compete with the social
media in terms of speed,
in terms of aggressiveness, then
quality journalism is important for
democracy because the classification of
topics of news can and should
do, but it only reaches
fewer people  have d  so the feeling that that
's right but the other is
at least as important as books
remain important as reading
remains important above all for young
people and just playing on the cell phone and just surfing
the internet
wouldn't be enough for me i  I had to
learn that that's also important you
know politics is above all
communication and the direct
possibility of communicating with people
we shouldn't
disregard but a good book and a
decent magazine and sensible
newspaper i wouldn't
want to measure you would still want to measure  your saying
from the past because there is this
legendary saying you need to govern
you need a picture bams and stare that's
not really up to date anymore or no
it's not that up to date anymore
I have nothing against television I watch
the news but not very very
much except of course  clear sport
football that's not a question but the
news both at today al  s also
because i
wouldn't want to do without ard regularly either but in fact
these electronic media are
losing their importance and they are losing their
importance all the more as they
try what is called social media
you are occasionally quite
social media if  i
look at the comments like this then if you
try to keep up with them
you will fail are they many
active so they have in the
facebook account but in the tram
no i didn't have my wife had an
instagram account on which i was of
course because  we are married and
also want to express life together in this
account i
myself am not without consequences on
linkedin you have to wait and see how much
of me i am we think we
have the live test of course i
actually have
34,000 followers here and yes  okay and also
regularly active i see you
even comment so every day you
are not there every day  but relatively
often once a week as
far as possible and
but really with encouragement and with
interesting comments from people
who saw the reading so a
completely new experience but an important
one question i wanted to ask him the
ghosts much closed again now  do
but let's look at the us election campaign
yes and you are now the age of
the candidates yourself or flat is the future
president of both at least of the
order of magnitude and
I think he is even older than
your parents now
if you look at the world that is
so for you say man i should
have stayed really active
longer as a politician or do you think how
can he manage that at the age as
your view of the situation yes i would
n't have a problem with that but after the
2005 election was lost  It was clear to me
that I would go back to my old
job as a lawyer and I would
be happy to do so because both when
dream jobs for me on the one hand
i always wanted to be a lawyer and
on the other hand to work politically and to
work as prominently as possible
that was also
successful and insofar as i am a
happy person but it is still a
question if we can assess it so well now
both
what it means to hold office and what it
means to be this age you
can maybe you want to be 40 now
i don't really want to assess exactly
again i've held office seven times
, i'm still that old and now
you always see holding it this way he
asks himself okay they are, so to speak, the
most powerful man in the world
quotation marks he already has it
's not necessarily that easy to know
so or say man you
don't have to worry he's fit
it's okay i think that in
america people tick differently
if you want to become president in that age, you have to be
fit and you have to ve  publish
that he is fit so basically
his health data is hardly any private
data anymore and my impression is that he has a more
flexible mind than the
current president so you are
probably quite happy is now who you
had already published different ones
that you say that  was
a very
problematic presidency yes i also
think that he divided the country
with his way of doing politics
he also harmed the media also
the really interesting media
take the new york times the washington
post by trying
to twitter them  to defame only because
you were occasionally critical that
doesn't work in a democracy
and trump divided the country more than it divided the
country well to death it
governed less than dividing it
he definitely used this social platform very strongly
so twitter
yourself facebook yourself what is your
view of this platform as  i
installed the most valuable companies in
the world, in part facebook
in particular or or google amazon
also how do you get that alright that
makes no sense to complain about it
that is part of our world that
is part of social and
economic progress i think
only that
you also have to have the opportunity when
something is published on these
platforms that really affects
the substance, the personal
substance and defamation whatever
, to defend oneself massively against it,
i occasionally have the impression that there are
people who are mine
in particular  in the companies themselves
that their entrepreneurial freedom
is more important than the
personal rights of those who, as
politicians, artists or whatever, are
occasionally abused
, not to say defamed
, there has to be a balance
between being able to defend yourself against
such networks and  the free  since
entrepreneurial freedom also freedom of the
press in precisely these networks
but you have probably also
understood how the exact
mechanisms work that
negative or polarizing
statements, so to speak, are often even more
widespread than moderate statements is that there
is already a basic problem that is a
basic problem and if that is in  Newspapers
magazines happens at least in
Germany you have every
opportunity to defend yourself against the courts
because of between freedom of the press on the
other hand and
personal rights on the second
side and that’s why I think the
same principle must also
apply in social media, so there is
still a little bit  I think
there is a need to catch up, because of course there are also
activists for whom freedom on the net
should remain infinite and respect for someone
else's personal rights is only
limited I think that's a shame
and they have this in front of the sheer
economic power  he film also
looks at germany with a certain respect
always has a look what these
companies are worth and like ours
we have for example with sap we also have
a very important player in this
area and now we should also take
care of it in my opinion of
course it will probably be probable  it has to
be like that, especially when
it comes to the question of how to deal with the volume of data,
europe is still a bit behind
, germany is just one
example,
digitization will be one of the
key issues in economic
development, as you know, my wife is korean and she
was  really
surprised that you have to open a door of
your own with a
key and that it doesn't work digitally and
in many other areas she was
surprised too and that was
progress that you need a week
to get an internet connection that's
okay there  one day you call in the
morning with that's it there we're
still there  a bit too slow in
germany when it comes to this question and
we have to catch up but is that
even noticeable when you
look at what you just mentioned they
are now worth something
over 100 billion and then
we are talking about google cell phones
there are a lot of them that will be ten times that
can it ever be
caught up i don't know but in
any case
you had to make an effort i
called sap that is a player who can
absolutely play on the same
level although in other areas  above all
in the area of supporting the e
onomy but at least you can be pr
ud of that and you should be and the e
ropean union has to think about resea
ch and devel
pment tasks this has more
o be invested in so i'll just give
ou an example that you're still
in  agriculture puts billions into it,
although the doubt is what's what,
what's the economy  I'm successful in
coming out and being more cautious in
education and investments in this
area it can't stay like this
do you believe in these European
projects that are financed with public money
there's the idea of
pean search engine or one o
its cloud offerings from Europ
that a chance
to say something like that public funds
look at the account i am not an expert
but i think that in many areas it
is important and if you
invest public funds then not in the
industries of the day before yesterday dollars in the
new industries we are also looking for  the
automotive industry, where we of course have to invest when it
comes to mobility, but i
add it quietly i sometimes find it
strange that the german
automotive industry pushes what it can really do
and what has not yet come to an
end, namely
diesel technology, into
the background a bit  let
me  age me sometimes how do we actually want to
solve transport problems in central
africa or also in asia do you really think
that could be done with e-
mobility where should the
charging station go that will
remain a mishmash between
conventional drives and what is
certainly important  and what
the big
germans are doing above all is a volkswagen daimler bmw, as they are all
called, but they shouldn’t do what they
really brought to the top,
namely this diesel technology,
just like an unloved child
then they had when they were commissioned by vw
and after that, as a former
auto chancellor, you are very close to the industry says
you have to test the wire that
you somehow already saw out of the corner of your eye or what
you all far too small and 40
relevant no unfortunately not in my day it
really wasn't of
any real relevance  and insofar
we have paid relatively little attention to it,
probably also ei  n
of course the members of the
supervisory board could not have come up with
that on their own, it really would have been the task
of the management and
germany waited a bit too long and that doesn’t just apply to
volkswagen but to the others as well
you could have
done both the
diesel technology wasn’t  sucked out
and should have been further
developed at the same time you
could have relied on e-mobility because the material possibilities were there and
it is very interesting that it is now in
brandenburg why are you in
brandenburg because germany is an
automotive country you
will still need it namely
industrial production in the
automotive industry is
better developed in germany than
anywhere else and that's why it was
a very smart decision from tesla
to go to brandenburg i think you
now know the large corporations as a
former left you know from the inside, among other
things  e structures are being
worked on again that’s also not so easy with the works
councils and with the bureaucracy that
then of course has to take place
now a
tesla like that comes along and the farmers in a very short
time but work and there’s a man
who seems to be there for you  everything
decides and says okay that’s how we do it
and everyone follows you get a
bit scared you think okay we are
now approaching it with completely different structures
I wouldn’t say to someone so scared
there is also there you can
learn from that, namely the speed of
the decision  are important, especially
with large investments, but
on the other hand what is the
secret of the success of our
social model? our social model? the
social market economy is so
successful because on the one hand we
say that economic competence is
necessary and economic strength and
development is necessary  the
other side but also say the same
what is needed is social equality, that
is, the german model, this balance
between economic success and
social justice, if this
balance is maintained, it is better
after the final in europe than, for example
, in america, you can also see that
with another topic now,
this kroner topic, that germany  has a
health system that is sometimes a
bit bureaucratic is also very
expensive, but in which everyone can be sure that they will get the best care they need for their illness, even if
they don’t have any money but are a public health insurance patient
,
that’s almost very
important for people absolutely  absolutely
nevertheless it is now so that maas led
for example if you have to talk to another company islam
now once have
become as strong as in
germany millions of people
who subscribe to amazon prime offer
the company is also worth an incredible amount of money
now you get the feeling  the
european union knows itself  so the only
thing left to do is to fight back with such patel lawsuits or pursue allegations of web
abuse yes i
follow that in general i believe
that the lawsuits must be observed, so to speak, an
occasional antitrust law must be
observed no question and if it is
violated you also have to
intervene but i think that is it  it's
not what you have to learn we have to
in germany is that you
need a works council and that it's good
for you because that avoids
conflicts within the company
that's what you can learn
from co-determination
and that's why i think it's always there  where
applicable law is
violated you have to intervene no
question even by taking legal action but that
must not be the central question the
central question must
be firstly to let the employees
participate in the success and
secondly to give them the opportunity to help
determine and  then americans will also
notice that it's not so
bad  t is for the economic
success because that is that my
experience of volkswagen i want to say very
clearly that the works councils and
those who
sit on the supervisory board as works council members are at least as interested in the success of the
company as the management because
these are their jobs and  the
jobs of the colleagues and that's
why it seems so if it's an
american company there are
also other areas where you
say what's the point of this co-determination when
you think about it and find out that
those who also have something to say
in their own company that they  also
work better then you would experience that there is
a balance between
co-determination on the one hand
and economic success on the
other hand are you a shareholder in
any of these tech companies
or generally become this spirit i
have i have no shares because that  is
always such a problem when you anyway
not at that time anyway because you get to know
one or the other thing and then it
would be a problem the active time
yes yes yes i have a share i think
vw is coming now no i have an idea
of 690 me which is afterwards i have a sha
e of  conti for the
following reason i had to make sure at the time as a
so-called guarantee that
the new owners
also comply with certain goals they had agreed on
and i could only do that if i was a shareholder
and that is why i bought a
share at a price of 28  euros and
that was so stupid of me because I would have
you such a 300,000 types of garden
because which wealthy man
okay but they say you didn’t
actually invest in the stock market in that sense
I’m a customer of the
Sparkasse in the nova very down to earth
let us know  is the subject changing
i want to know who talked to the
usa a little bit about
talking about russia because that's also a
topic for  r it is very important to you that
somehow plays a big role
how is your daily or
supervisory board so there you are actively making it
difficult where i am
chairman of the supervisory board of
rosneft the largest company in the world is much
larger than exxon that is always
forgotten even though the  but we have
that is an international company
look they are listed on the stock exchange in london the owners
are not only is
not just the russian state or the
holding company of the russian state but owners
so the owner is qatar the
svp to a significant extent that an
international company and  very
successful but of course also at the
moment one or the other problem but
less than others and the second is
that the pipeline companies are the
two only 21 100 92 and i
'm really convinced because if we
on the one hand what is
organized  got out of nuclear energy as chancellor
and out of the one on
the other side  because of the climate issues, we wo
n’t be able to keep hard coal and lignite in the long term, yes,
then we need some
options and renewables alone
won’t
be able to do that, at least in the foreseeable future, so
we need gas as a transitional technology,
that’s also important, it’s also
a lot in terms of environmental policy  better than the
other fossil energy carriers and
that's why i have no problem at all
with getting involved there and especially
the gas that we get through the pipelines is
significantly
cheaper than what the americans are happy to
sell us one more question
maybe because they  danes have addressed the council for phasing out nuclear energy
do they realize that a lot of
investors are
venture capitalists who are
economic visionaries aren’t they
crazy now that
they’re saying this whole phasing out of nuclear energy is actually not possible so we have
to change that too, the technology is
changing there too  much safer there
are maybe smaller reactors
so that's what you say if you really
want to act in an environmentally friendly way in the future
we'll have to obviously
then there's no way around nuclear energy
what if that's it he knows
them they mean so i
understood none at all  i ask i have a
different opinion because the central
problem that made us
say we have to because of this is the
lack of disposal that means nobody
knows what to do with the spent fuel
rods we still don’t have a single
final repository we have an intermediate layer but
not a single one  endlager now the
commission that deals with it on
behalf of the federal government has decided
gorleben is not possible everyone has
always looked there and i have always
said so
prime minister of lower saxony in
gorleben nothing is buried except potatoes
and and now the bavarians,
interestingly enough, refuse as big supporters
the core one
rgy to think about whether
a safe repository could not be built in the granite of Bavaria
, that
is, the renaissance will fail due to the
lack of disposal and that is why
there is no point in thinking about
what we really need to bring forward
are the renewable
energy sources that do that  we are also better
than everyone else in the world and we
need guests for a transitional period how
do you have to imagine it now that you are the head of the
supervisory board of such a
global corporation, are you challenged every day
or is it not yet
technology but the
supervisory
board meetings that take place in person now, so to speak
fewer than before four to six
times a year are the continuous hello, have a
nice day and that is very
intensive what is being done there and
there are also
the possibilities that are also used
because of digitization because
of the important decisions from here
influence
that's no problem at all because
we're equipped in such a way that we
can do it without many people being able
to overhear it i didn't even
look it up so 64 billion is let's look at the current
market capitalization of
rosneft if it were a german
company it would be one of the largest companies
Germany and we would indeed have to
, yes, but that's
okay and
I'm also happy to learn
what problems there are for this, also on
international television, for
example to see how the conditions are
in opec, for example, where
Russia isn't really  member is
how that is regulated in order to be able to make
reasonably reasonable pricing policy and also
funding policy that is
already a new experience is granted
is you going to do it how can that
actually so that
you are asked to tell this office
you won’t be anything now so clear you
were chancellor germany is
already kinda great  njobs
obviously, but they just
called or they were in fact
looking for someone who, so to speak, respects both
the international investors,
i.e. qatar or bp, but also
the Russian majority and
then we are open and I hope
you know me very badly  so if you read the media
and prepare yourself a bit then it
is that your relationship with putin
somehow comes sooner or later to the point
that you
let it be addressed that you have
such a friendship or that is
in fact a friendship that
started in  during our active time so in
mine he is still active but that
also
continued afterwards in us maybe two
three times a year who is of course not
not because of me because of him he
really has a lot on his mind to govern this
country is damn not
simple and something has developed
in the human area that i do
n't miss m  would like in my experience
and therefore weather is always
asked are you friends we and
i have nothing nothing that can
then you go together so not about
dinner or owner that you can
that then it’s
not that easy then again so we can’t  playing together in
a
pub a that there is also
he is always his sport because I would have
no chance of power judo he rides
as you know that's all in
public
there I wouldn't
have had the slightest chance I want my bones  areas
with judo
so then really now at the meal
just pretend that it was and
we don't discuss
German politics but we keep
that apart you think he's impressed how he also
operates the keyboard of the image there  he
now he lets the photographer
prepare her shirtless and that's how
you think that's deliberately
staged so would m  yes you
know i really don't know but that
's not under the
do you actually watch if, for
example, mrs
merkel is making video messages and also podcasts
no i don't watch them but i
watched a government statement
on tv and we talk occasionally
also with each other that's how it is yes yes yes
that what i was looking for advice no she
doesn't need any advice from me there is
occasionally yes occasionally they
too for example when it comes
to helping a journalist in turkey
to come back to germany
this  mr yüksel you talk to him and
then you are asked if you can
be helpful you
could and then you also talk about it it
's clear so in germany
thank god it's different than it is in america at the
moment the political opponent isn't an
enemy is an opponent  that's a bit
different to what trump has done in
america, he has national holidays via
twitter  nd
statements and has thus divided the country in
a way that is simply
bad all of the country is too important
not only for itself and for the
American citizens
and should for the world and what should
such a divided America can do its
tasks  as one of the most important
world powers only to a limited extent and
that's why it's so good that both
won, because maybe
not that much will change in this matter, not
even the controversies
we have in the economic area
, but the style will be
different  and that's a
start to get into a better
conversation with each other on the server
you sometimes get annoyed that russia is
viewed so negatively here in germany
or your friendship with russia is
viewed so critically in general and that's
that's a media story and
That's unfortunate because
if you look around a
bit, then look around  ß it was
always peaceful on this continent
and there were perspectives
when the relationship between
western europe and russia was okay,
especially germany is okay
was it was different in the first and
second world wars there were catastrophes
and that’s why i think it will be closed
little thought about how important the country is
as
yes as not only for the economy in
germany is for the raw materials not
only no also politically to
ensure peaceful development on this continent
for the next generations
and the accusations that
are always made because they
especially with a view to the ukraine and
you can understand that said
that is you know that you have to
live with that when you go into politics now
so nice we have to the kitchen is too
hot because he is not allowed to cook who are old
weeks  now also quite convinced
of lower saxons or
hanoverians now i think is the aim of
many st  other places in
germany to operate a kind of
cluster formation to become a strong cluster especially and
tech cluster if you look at it now
as national glasses, so to speak, then
it makes no sense that there are now munich
and hannover and berlin and then the
ruhr area or cologne and hamburg so
many clusters  can't there be
how are two children the
national glasses and you know
the hannoverian glasses
or the lower saxony glasses, so to speak, the defense
had to step down because a country can tolerate so many tech
clusters and future clusters,
well let's
say digitization  it
is the task of every
society and every country
to help develop i would always say ok we have
characterized the automotive industry with volkswagen we
have functioning
suppliers in lower saxony why don't we make a cluster we have around wolfsburg when it comes to
mobility why don't we make a
cluster  what to  m example the question concerns
sales so logistics he will become more and more
important they talked about him
so these are areas in
which we can
and should romp around and then i think
it would be good if we were to lead the
mobilization of venture capital for
start  oops
that's not just a government
task, but also occasionally
one experiences that the banks are too
cautious and perhaps one
could be in this area about
the institutions that exist in the country,
so the development agencies that we
have much more yours
orient grandpa because when you start out you
usually have little capital but a lot on your mind
and if you do something it's a brave
one that would be for hannover you're something like that in
hannover we don't want it there are
such approaches we have here for
example in the city of hannover that is
an old building that is here
and where one then
tries to enable companies to settle  praise those
who can also pay,
i think such aspects need to be given much more
attention because the central
question is how do we deal with start-ups,
how do we deal with young people who have graduated
from university or are still there and
who need venture capital  a
nice term in and venture capital
means yes something should be dared
fine and if the public sector then has
to write something off okay we
write as much as possible then he can
say something but say that yes even
say about the thesis yes even
venture capitalist for a good idea there
is already a lot of money on the market
that he obviously and for a good
idea and a really promising
team there is a lot of private demand
you can see now in germany there
are start-ups that get reviews
and cash  in syringes
say benefits like never before so they still believe
that there really show that public
funds investier  t
should be if necessary if necessary
if but if private money is there and
invested and so better only many
are not yet at the level to get
the whole capital but in
the early phase you obviously need
a nudge and  do we
often only need support with bureaucratic issues, for example
ok if you ask another question how much
the departure but often not
unimportant
if you have to wait a long time for a decision
then a lot of capital is
lost
there are politicians in germany these
say people who are doing the right thing
well there is but you we don't want to tell you
one who
might not be immediately understood as a
politician who does a
damn great job that the wife of the
federal president yes that's just
look at this couple the two
represent a modern germany
in a certain and  very intelligent
at the same time humble and a
not insignificant  part of it is of
course first and foremost the federal president
himself that is clear but a
not inconsiderable part he
would never deny it has ms
büdenbender his wife who does it in a very
self-confident at the same time modest
way
so that’s caliber ok so that she the others  others were
surprised
when i was supposed to look for some
where should they come from but i'll
tell you i was very skeptical
about a younger spd politician, mr
had dinner
in berlin
and then i thought it was quite remarkable
and we watched what is he
doing now and then i
read an interview in zeit about the
question of how to
deal with the people who are
islamist here  does not actuate islam so
islamists and ask radically that
was I could have said al  so he's
on the right track i think i was
actually getting somewhere
else okay but i came out of that corner sometimes
okay okay and internationally they had
something like that in the election campaign there was together before there
were two determined
opponents yes i think  that the vice-
president is really remarkable yes she
is the type and also in terms
of what she says and from which
political corner you have to say an
impressive woman
because the background is so
unusual yes
not that and don't say bad
if  you know where you come from you
also know where you belong
ok
then follow what you
do these various american
company leaders do they
know from north so that it also
limits an english firstly i can
now discuss in english about
the brics it and about  europe and the
prospects of europe about the
relationship with russia but i
can't follow what
what is happening in the american economy apart from what is
being read about it in the german business
newspapers, the readers are already dancing and have the feeling that sometimes the german media landscape, since
we are perhaps strongly colored in one direction,
sometimes
there are no points of view, that's the way it is  say those
who the media
still miss this diversity 30 40 years ago
yes that's true a bit but that
is worked through by the
possibility to inform yourself via the internet
if you do that and if you can
do that and i had to learn  then you
have a lot of
information that is helpful but
if, like me, you are not necessarily active on the
stock market, then you
don’t have to go into the internal ones are
you now with corona and all the
topics that are last for us, so to speak
months have been
optimistic looking at the next
let's say three four year yes will
de  utchland i am if i absolutely i
think by the way i have no
reason to criticize that the
federal government did it all in all
properly and these
conferences with the prime minister
okay that is difficult because it is difficult to
deal with them yourself but all in
all  we got through this
pandemic crisis quite well, of course,
it's not over yet and
that's why I thought it was right that
this part of the lockdown was now
ordered and I hope that those who
think that a conspiracy by bill
gates or someone else is doing it
come to their senses so i'm surprised
sometimes it's not my
business to criticize but i'm
sometimes surprised how such a
higher administrative court then simply says
no even if we know that they
don't stick to the rules that then
exist again then they should have  let's take a
demonstration in the middle of town that
would occasionally ic  I wish that
the seriousness
that is necessary to overcome this pandemic
is also reflected in the
judgments of the administrative courts
, but you get the feeling
that many people are still a
bit afraid of the future, which I
have become even faster,
then the question is who is it  from
Germany in the world then
the climate question comes up all the time you
should get a
very optimistic outlook in
the medium term I would
definitely do that and by the way
a book will be published in January that
gives the answers to your questions  when your book
is
remembered that means we're called the book the
book is called the last chance the west has
to reinvent itself we really have to
draw conclusions from the changed world situation and
I'll try that together with the
mail the historians in attain
is going to send out we  have developed this book together
, trying to sort it out a
bit  then we want to see what's going to
happen but they look nice yes I
say yes that's fine I'm
curious I probably have a few theses
we should know we hear in your
podcast they also stand
generally if you research two is
quite interesting them  are
still very present so there is i
saw when you googled
google news i think within
a week they published in
the welt in the handelsblatt so and
a third
portal was also an article by
you are really very active  that's
your voice and it's important for that too
look at it stays political in
the end so operational politics is over for
me that's not a question at all but if you've been
involved in politics all your life and get involved in politics it
doesn't stop when  suddenly you no
longer have an office like wilk 1 will take the
individual but that's why
i have to comment on politics what's the
name of it ir  at some point, as a politician, you
will become what you take as a politician
and know that you will never get rid of it again
that is now changing with the climate that is
the last complex of topics that
he did not play that big of a
role in your time these questions
are somehow huge now  and when the corona
is gone, i assume
they will get
even bigger, so to speak, old
promises exist, first of all, this is an
absolutely serious topic and i don’t think
it’s that bad when very
young people say this will be our
life and we want each other now  get involved
whether then everything is correct
what one or the other is doing there is
another matter and whether there are
not also
institutions behind it that are not only interested in the matter
in any case i would
say they are now young
getting people involved in these
activities is better than
not getting involved and they make
politics a bit too  under pressure
otherwise it would certainly occasionally
change too little and in that respect i already
have enough so do you think that says
i think i think that you have to look at
this question too take
the exit from lignite of
course that is the
right decision under climatic conditions  but
it was also right that you
want to realize them on the timeline because
it also depends on the livelihoods
of the parents, by the way,
but also the livelihoods of the children,
which perhaps doesn't go
fast enough and to that extent and the
mill counts in a democracy  one has
to acknowledge that the
decisions in the in doubt are made a
little more slowly than in
a dictatorship
just what do we want but do we have
the time to think about it i'm also
big on democracy and all the
advantages half of it will be too  but nobody can give
him an answer to the
question of whether we still have time, we m  must
make it quick but the
structures the democratic structures
in which we make the decisions
not only because of the pressure from the street
i'm really in favor of demonstrations
, i used to take part in them myself
simply let them be overridden ie
if we want to keep both a
democratic decision-making and
improve the situation as quickly as possible
we are talking about climate issues
then we need to know
someone who can govern alone that
more per ordre de mufti china yes,
for example if it happens and but
that is not yet our picture of the
future because we want the young
people  Not only do we want to leave behind a future worth living in
terms of
climate,
but we also want to leave you a
democracy, but you have to
learn in democracy that
decision-making in democracy is
occasionally slower than you
might think is right,
but you are sitting in the question now  I was
in a severe dilemma, of
course, but I think that this
dilemma day exists in all
modern societies and if you
want and have to solve it democratically and
we should want and should we
have to, then you need a little more time
than when you get through  being able to decide
deals with the climate questions
so say also operationally with some
topics you are obviously
very
close to it because of your experience in life because
you have been in charge of the automotive industry for years and
say or have experienced and and
energy policy and such but it is
about 2000 climate issues  is it also the case
that the witnesses know these scientific
aspects so well or is no
i don't know them as well as you
should know it would be exaggerated
if i wanted to stylize myself as someone who
knows everything there is to know about this question  to offer in science
is i live try to
read what people like edenhofer  and others
say and write about it but i
would not consider myself an expert in
these questions
again maybe because i tried
your life experience and
optimism which is very
pleased i yes that you say man
i have a positive view of them now
next years in germany
where does it come from so what is very
good let's see what have we
done since the second world war
how solid is a democracy built up and
whether there are a few people from the afg
or something like
that it's everywhere but  secondly, that we do
n't question the core of our democratic
development. secondly, we have built
a social
model that is based on the social
market economy because, for the
first time in german history, there is
also an adequate life for the workforce and
those who are too old, too young, too ill
are not
quite fully everyone knows that but a
decent life that a
a social model that is second to none in the
world and that has to be defended
and that's what makes me optimistic
because i think most people
here in germany know that it's
worth defending for themselves
and for the prospects of their children
and grandchildren, but that's all there is to it
also built on the economic
strength that we have that's was that's why
i say anyone
who wants to govern this country must also take care of the
economic strength that
not only concern themselves with the question of fair
distribution, only
what has been worked out can be distributed
and don't worry
that the economic power will
suffer a bit, so to speak, if you
look at it now let's take a look at the
automotive industry
tesla isn't worth almost a factor 10
as much as the germans it's
not just about value  it's
about it, it's not just about the
stock market value of a company  rn it
's also about what we produce there
and who participates in the production
and there are not only the shareholders there
are also the cities as we know so in
this respect the model that we have in
Germany is one that is a much
fairer election victory for the development
of  society than anywhere else i have to
honestly say i currently only want to live in
america as an absolutely wealthy person
otherwise it's not
okay and i mean in the end it's
then we can say it doesn't matter who owns the
tesla factory there ingrünheide the main thing is
that the work is done by german
people and well  I'm for
investments from which the tesla
invests, I think it's great and whether it belongs to
the owner or not that
's secondary if the
work organization is organized the way
we think it's right with
co-determination with works
councils everything will be as it should be  I, on the other hand
, have the same opinion,
why shouldn't Chinese investors
invest in Germany?  Swiss invest just as
well as
Americans, no problem at all
, you have to look. There are certain
areas, for example the
defense industry, where this is
not possible, but in every country,
for example, to start a debate
about whether to participate in the G5
networks  should i think it's
nonsensical we have to be technologically
able to protect what we
want to protect namely information
if germany can no longer do
that who should be able to then
that means they would be allowed to
there the slide i don't have it
problem
and do you have a general social view
of china a bit concerned that
somehow i recently turned to the
cell phones for the podcast
raffinesse for vreden were as a
general sales market for germany
if someone says we can handle it
quite well on our own we'll now take all of
these
We don't need German cars anymore, then of course we'll have
them  lich here from one day to
the next a huge problem because
neither our games will not
make it that means at the same time that we
always have to be better so what
others can do that's what you take
competition what I
think is wrong, so to speak  accusing the chinese
of wanting to
do something themselves, that they want to
develop, we
all were our friends when we viewed them as
extended workbenches, so to
speak, at the moment when they become
competitors, we
suddenly start thinking about administrative measures
against it in  besides, we are
a country that
lives from the openness of the markets and you are so
we should deny others what we ourselves want
and that is why
i believe that this attempt
to slow down the development of china is
the core of the trade war
between america and  china is
not going well and
we shouldn't worry about it  share but someone
this risk is that i him he has to
worry about himself yes there is no
risk-free life in the
globalized world as we know
everything is clear so i think
thank you very much
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr